I honestly think that having a maternity
leave that is this short it makes you
have to decide do you want to be a
mother to your children or do you want
to pursue your career the u.s. is the
only advanced economy in the world that
doesn't have federal paid leave for
parents after they have a child there is
the Family and Medical Leave Act but
that allows for only 12 weeks of unpaid
leave I think we need to have a parental
leave that allows women to establish
themselves as mothers I think we need an
equivalent paternity leave obviously men
aren't breastfeeding but that doesn't
prevent them from staying up at night
with the baby it doesn't prevent them
from being equal parents to the mother
to allow both parents to pursue careers
the problem is that FMLA only covers
about forty percent of us workers and in
order to even be eligible you need to
work for a company with over 50
employees and have worked for them for
at least one year so low wage workers
often don't qualify and you have to be
able to afford to take time off with no
pay I'm not really interested in taking
unpaid leave being able to keep a steady
income in our house is important and
that's a challenge facing many families
for those people who can't afford to
take unpaid time off I think it's unfair
to allow these parents who are in really
a fragile state after having their baby
to have to decide between paying their
bills or staying home with their child
only three states offer additional
benefits that allow parents to take more
time off at a fraction of their salary
studies have shown that paid parental
leave leads to lower rates of postpartum
depression and infant mortality parents
with premature and at-risk babies
especially struggle with the lack of
parental leave one in ten babies were
born preacher
in 2014 in the US that means that those
moms had to begin using their parental
leave early with Hezekiah he was born
early he was born at 29 weeks my husband
put his wedding ring through his arm and
it went all the way up to his shoulder
he ended up on a ventilator for three
months he had two surgeries and he
didn't come home until after his due
date he was born in January and
hinkelman April the idea of going back
to work while my son was in the hospital
still having surgeries I didn't even get
to hold him until he was two weeks old
for dad's paternity leave has become
more widely accepted in the last decade
paternity leave is one of the most
important times that you have as a
parent that as a father you are there
with your newborn child that relies on
other people including you for
absolutely everything you're there
supporting the mother of your child who
for a period of time is physically not
able to do much other than directly care
for the baby despite the lack of paid
parental leave laws in the US there are
some momentum happening around the issue
the state of New York for example has
approved the most progressive state plan
that will be fully implemented in 2021
eligible workers will get 12 full weeks
of paid leave along with job protection
our family is not in a position where we
can go with just one income I've always
thought of myself as a career woman I
also think of myself as a mother and I
love being a mother it's been really
hard to just kind of
walk away during a time where I know the
thing gave me the most